I do have to say this is one of the
emptiest Park entrances I have ever seen
it's already long past opening time and
it's still this quiet which I guess is
pretty good
[Music]
so this video is about one of my last
days living in Japan and realizing that
there were two roller coasters high on
my bucket list that I didn't get to ride
yet Kawa semi at tobu zoo and bend it at
Yomiuri land so I figured I would visit
both of these parks in one day and be
back in time to get a haircut and have
dinner in the evening which made for a
pretty tight schedule I'll explain more
along the way but now let's get back to
tobu zoo for a second so this is
definitely the emptiest Park that I've
ever been ever it feels like I'm one of
the only guests in the park at all I
could see a few other people here and
there but other than that it's
completely empty which is kind of
strange considering it's a Saturday and
the weather isn't even all that bad but
the views are pretty fantastic already
got a really cool view of Regina the
woody over there and I think one of the
first things I just want to do is head
over to kama semi and see how that one
is really looking forward to that that's
one of the roller coasters that I've
been looking forward to riding most in
Japan and it's one of those it's been
taking me half a year to finally get
here so yeah let's go Kawa semi is
generally known as one of the best
smallest roller coasters in the world
it's the first coaster of the intamin
mega lights model which gives you pretty
much the experience of a mega or hyper
coaster like Goliath or Millennium Force
on a tiny 31 metre tall layout and God
this thing actually lives up to the hype
despite how small this ride is it is
absolutely an air time machine the first
drop is pretty good for how low it
really is there's a curve at the bottom
of it where you get some nice forces and
then you go into this twisted airtime
Hill underneath the lift hill which is
all pretty nice there you get into the
biggest airtime Hill to ride which is
already a lot more violent than anything
so far in the ride and then you go into
these twisted airtime Hills which is
personally my favorite part because
these really throw you out of your seat
pretty violently and the ride ends with
a bunch of small bunny hops with again
some pretty good airtime before you go
back into the station so all-in-all this
layout might just be the most
perfect layout for its size I honestly
cannot imagine making a better layout
for how small this ride is you get a
really wide range of airtime some nice
spacing and super smooth curves all I
can say is that there should definitely
be more of these intimate mega lights in
the world
[Music]
so tobe zoo isn't only about cover semi
there's also Regina which is by far the
second best ride in the park I would say
and arguably the best wooden roller
coaster in Japan considering how few
there are in Japan it's not that much of
an achievement but if you're a fan of
classic Woody's then this is probably
the best thing you'll get it's also a
rare coaster with a distinctly female
name and logo and everything even the
advertisement for it back in the day
managed to sexually objectify a roller
coaster of all things but I guess we can
chalk that up to Japan being Japan
anyway it's a fun ride and it's a really
nice bonus when you go there to ride
cover semi I wouldn't say that it's
something to travel to the park for and
go out of your way to ride but it's just
a really classic out in back layouts
with some drops and mostly on banked
turns there's not a lot of airtime on it
and it's pretty shaky but it's not
shakey to the point where it's
uncomfortable I think it just
contributes to the the out of control
wooden coaster fuel that you get on the
ride so overall great wooden coaster
probably the best in Japan and
definitely pick it up if you're at the
park anyway
[Music]
now this is probably no surprise to you
but Toby zoo also has a zoo section so I
decided to check that out for a bit and
it's it's pretty disappointing to be
honest granted there was some snow which
is really rare for Tokyo and it doesn't
really help with all the palm trees and
the subtropical foliage and all of that
so the zoo didn't really look very good
but aside from that I think the animal
enclosures are just really small and
poorly themed
so the whole place just looks a little
bit sad the monkeys had a pretty nice
onsen though I also went to the Penguins
because Toa Zoo is or was the home of
grape kun which is a famous penguin who
fell in love with an anime girl cutouts
in his enclosure unfortunately though
grape can died a while ago and all the
anime girls are gone so it's not much to
visit the zoo section for anymore so I
decided to head back to the theme park
section to write cover sent me a few
times again and then it was time to
travel across Tokyo and go to your
Island
yummy Island is located on a hill in the
east of Tokyo and because of that it has
some awesome views over the city you can
even see the skyline of Shinjuku from
there I didn't go for that specifically
though I just wanted to ride this
particular coaster banned it when this
thing opened in 1988 it was the fastest
ghost in the world and though it's
technically not the first hyper coaster
because it mostly conforms to the
terrain the height difference within the
ride is 78 meters so that is pretty
intense actually for how old this thing
is and this might just be the best Togo
coaster in the world it's pretty smooth
all things considered it has some nice
airtime moments a really forceful helix
and just great views over the skyline of
Tokyo also I was allowed to wear my
glasses and take my backpack on the ride
which considering how huge the drops on
this thing are and the fact that it's
Japan and I usually care a lot about
safety that was a really nice surprise
now another surprisingly good Togo
coaster in this park is the release
strangely named Momonga standing loop
coaster before I went on it I thought it
would hurt intensely considering that
it's the first stand-up coaster ever
built and it's also built by Togo which
has pretty horrible reputation to begin
with but this ride firm is actually
really enjoyable as well it's pretty
smooth and has a really forceful in an
almost circular loop and the trains are
pretty comfortable for a stand-up
coaster so yeah
somehow this park managed to get a bunch
of actually good Togo coasters but even
though it has some good rights
I think Yomiuri land is mostly known for
the winter illuminations which you can
see all over the park and they
definitely look great at nights but
before I got dark I wanted to ride spin
runway a right which I didn't even know
existed before I looked at Yomiuri lands
website but it's a really fun indoor
spinning coaster with a really creative
runway theme it's a great replacement
for twists coaster robin which operated
on the same place for only a few hours
before it crashed and shut down forever
anyway after that I ended the nights by
checking out the illuminations across
the park and I highly recommend you do
the same if you visit this place in
winter because the park is built on a
hill you have a really great view of the
lights from the highest
places in the park and even the track
and trains of bandits have these light
strips on them that make for an
amazing-looking coaster to look at at
night so yeah that's it for tobu zoo and
Yomiuri land all in all for both of
these parks seven out of ten would
recommend at least if you're in the
Tokyo area and you're into theme parks
thanks for watching guys and I'll see
you all next time